hello welcome to PlayStation grenade the
remake of Resident Evil 2 will go down
as one of the greatest games of 2019 and
will likely spawn remakes of all the
other titles in the series during my
playthrough I spot lead 28 Easter eggs
and secrets like mobster culture most
are callbacks to the original Resident
Evil 2 from back in 1998 but there are
also a bucketload of TV film and a few
anime references which are easy to miss
so if you ready let's do this as the
opening credits roll on Resident Evil 2
they somehow feel familiar this is due
to the influence of The Walking Dead TV
show The Shoppes the slow pans the
creepy flyovers have all been used in
this way in The Walking Dead for almost
ten years
to be honest I'm sure the Walking Dead
wasn't the first to do this to build
atmosphere quickly but they are
definitely the most well known
[Music]
The Walking Dead get a second nod
through this alternative costume for
Leon to make him look like Rick Grimes
in his sheriff outfit more about
alternative costumes in a little bit for
more years than I can remember Resident
Evil fans have begged Capcom to remake
Ari - well that day finally came in 2015
by producer Hirabayashi who I'm going to
call H from now on because there's no
chance I can pronounce out twice
correctly anyway he confirmed the remake
like this when you're doing yourself we
do it literal translations from Japanese
into English never go to well but the
community loved it and guess what it's
in the game find this bust in the
waiting room just off the first hallway
and look at the motto at the bottom we
do it I'm gonna buy that t-shirt over in
the main office for the local police
force is a lovingly made banner
welcoming Leon on his birthday in the
team this is yet another 1998 reference
to the same location in the original
game the Eagle I'd noticed back then
that there were two L's in the word
welcome luckily in the remake they got
this right first time hang on wait a sec
is that a subtle space where another L
could have been placed searching around
the office you'll find that additional L
good thing it was taken down this could
have been embarrassing it's also worth
noting the names of officers on each of
the desks here one in particular has
importance Rita Phillips Rita appeared
alongside Marvin in Resident Evil
Outbreak
file - this game struggled to gain
traction and was very hard to get your
hands on especially where I live maybe
this will be another game which gets the
remake treatment
in the same room is an easter egg of an
easter egg make your way over to the
lockers and you'll spot this one
Jojo those that played back in 1998 will
recognize the word and the font as it
matches are perfectly from Marvin's
first ever seen above two months ago
there was this incident involving these
zombie-like creatures this is in fact
though a nod to the team's love of the
anime JoJo's Bizarre Adventure from back
in the 1980s and 90s coincidentally
Capcom made a video game based on that
cartoon series - as we're already
talking about references to other video
games let's go further down the rabbit
hole in many outdoor locations posters
flyers and general graffiti can be found
even building names are callbacks to
other Capcom titles another returning
easter egg from 20 years ago is the
building named a ruckus what we got to
do here is read it backwards and you'll
be gifted with the name of a character
from yet another Capcom title Sakura
from Street Fighter although I always
get told off I'm saying that wrong
Sakura better backwards writing
continues with this repair star a wagon
Lee's one reversed we get Shinagawa
another Capcom employee who worked most
noticeably on Megaman once you reach
Raccoon City look around for this docile
zombie chillin by a window the poster
next to her is advertising a freelance
photographer named Frank East those that
have played another Capcom IP Dead
Rising will recognize this as a
reference to Frank West who is a
freelance photographer tasked with
staying alive in a zombie filled
shopping center in the original Dead
Rising there are more similarities
between those two games this actually
may be the same universe as there's the
Colombian Roast masters cafe appearing
in both games one of my favorite Easter
eggs in that series was the subway
inspired Jill sandwiches that was a nod
to the Resident Evil series and this
scene where Jill is almost crushed to
death and then Barry hits her with some
comedy that was too close you were
almost a Jill sandwich legend some
eagle-eyed players have spotted this in
the re - remake in the RPG operations
room scrawled on a note which reads Jill
sandwiches
back to obscure references to the
original game before walk into the gas
station at the start of the game look at
the staff Wanted sign the telephone
number reads 199 800 129 which so
happens to be the original release date
of Resident Evil 2 29th of January 1998
back in the operations room there is a
map to grab but look at what is left
underneath
I quickly googled these names and found
that all these people worked on Resident
Evil 2 such as Miguel corty who's a
Japanese English translator and grey
McRobbie who works on localization on
numerous Capcom titles while Capcom
employees can be found in the main hall
under the statue at the back of the room
how cool is it to be immortalized in the
games world rather than in the end
credits which I'm sure we all don't pay
attention to let's jump back over to the
gas station at the start of the game
take a second to look at the ice cream
key ingredient it's none other than
herbes or herbs I really do prefer the
American way herbs in this universe
everyone goes around eating flora and
fauna in fact the second Easter Egg can
be found regarding those herbs on the
completion screen of the one-shot demo a
green sticky note reads to whomever
keeps doing this could you please stop
eating the office greenery I don't care
if you say it makes you feel better
those herbs cost money the license
plates in re to have relevance to Leon's
Jeep has the number plate Mathilde which
is also the name of his favourite weapon
but did you know that his name and his
weapon are named in homage to the film
Leon the professional in this movie Leon
gets a new perspective on life after a
chance run-in with Natalie Portman's
character and yes you guessed it she's
called Matilda it's also a great film so
if you haven't watched it already I
highly recommend it Claire's license
plate on the other hand reads MD 3 H 3
VN designed to look like made in heaven
is also on her jacket too in the police
department get over to Chrissy's desk in
the stars office and he has that on his
jacket too
the same phrase definitely peas in a pod
this brother and sister
speaking of attire we've already
mentioned Liam's walking dead sheriff
outfit but there's a few more to quickly
look at Leon has a noir costume designed
to look like that used in another Capcom
title the evil
within Claire on the other hand gets the
iconic Elsa Walker outfit who was
intended to be the lead character in
Resident Evil 2 before the story was
rewritten and Claire took her place the
only similarity that made it across was
their love of motorcycles the movie The
Shining plays an important part in the
creation of early Resident Evil games to
signify this Redrum could be found
scrawled across walls in the original
and anyone who's seen the shining knows
this is murder written backwards it's
also the reason why all the names on
buildings are written in Reverse so we
can hide Easter eggs in them in the
remake the shining reference is much
more profound and prominent and happens
during the section played as Sheree does
this ring any bells
here's Johnny if you know your resident
evil timelines you'll know that resident
evil 3 takes place both before and after
Resident Evil 2 for that to remain the
case in the updated games we can look
for evidence and subtle nods I found
three to ponder the first can be found
in the second run-through of the game in
1996 a star's team member named Brad
Vickers saved everyone with his expert
flying skills including Jill Valentine
in 1998 he could be found living the
undead lifestyle yes sadly he became a
zombie he was hidden away under the
under path back in 2019 he's still here
but he is not a member of the undead
opening the door here will reveal a
poster of Brad so in this universe he is
yet to meet his demise at the hands of
the tyrant we call nemesis
and speaking of nemesis his job was to
hunt down and murder stars team members
hence the constant shouting off
have you noticed the walls have already
been knocked through before mr. X
arrived this is undoubtedly thanks to
the nemesis tracking down Jill Valentine
and there's one more Resident Evil three
reference to uncover on the streets it's
possible to locate a building
advertising
Mikhail's pierogies authentic Russian
cuisine this is in respect to Mikael
Viktor an umbrella operative with a love
of sweetly savory dumplings from Russia
spoiler alert here Mikhail's resident
evil 3 adventure didn't go too well but
at least he went out with a bang
have you played Resident Evil 7 if you
have you'll already know that you've
seen many animations before such as
opening electronic boxes are using the
bolt cutters this is due to the same
engine being used to make both games
what you may not have noticed are the
mannequins from re 7 they are here to
add atmosphere to the world keep looking
around and you'll see a host of reused
assets including a magazine written
about the events of Resident Evil 2 how
the hell did it go back in time maybe
we'll find out in Resident Evil 8 the
biggest Easter egg back in 1998 was
found when in the Stars team office
searching the desk of Albert Wesker 50
times gave us a roll of film which when
developed gave us a photo of an 18 year
old Rebecca chambers in a suggestive
pose which is really weird really weird
it gets even more pervy because that
Easter egg returns in the remake but has
different steps to unlock finding a roll
of film in the sewers then developing it
will show a picture of a desk visiting
that desk you've guessed it it's
Wesker's will reward us with a high
caliber magazine and the second roll of
film which so happens to be Rebecca
again what dirty pervert from the moral
of the story remember what happens to
dirty perverts
okay let's finish off with a greatest
moment of the 1998 iteration of Resident
Evil 2 found in the 2019 version the
terrifying moment the liquor dashes past
the window can only be found in the
second playthrough this is the same for
the iconic reveal of the liquor when you
reach this section in your second
playthrough stand still and the liquor
will demonstrate his class tongue action
come down there Clare just like he did
back in 1998 there are so many more
forms of the original game hidden in the
second playthrough so do yourself a
favor play both Clare and Leon second
scenarios whoa we did it 28 references
and secrets found in Resident Evil 2
remake thank you very much for watching
I really do appreciate it so far what is
your favorite moment in this game for me
it's getting clobbered by this yeah
highlight of my day imagine from
PlayStation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]